E
STRIKE YOUR LVIV IN A MOMENT BUT
FIRST, WE BEGIN WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT, THE WHITE HOUSE WALKING
BACK EXPLOSIVE COMMENTS MADE BY
PRESIDENT BIDEN A FEW HOURS AGO
HE CALLS FOR REGIME CHANGE IN
RUSSIA.
>> I AM REBUILDING AN EMPIRE.
PEOPLE'S LOVE FOR LIBERTY.
A BRIGHTER FUTURE ROOTED IN
DEMOCRACY, OPEN LIFE, DECENCY
AND DIGNITY AND POSSIBILITY OF
FREEDOM.
THIS MAN CANNOT REMAIN IN POWER.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE FOLLOWED UP
WITH A STATEMENT TELLING FOX
NEWS NOT ASSESSING PUTIN'S POWER
IN RUSSIA OR REGIME CHANGE.
".
BIDEN ALSO SAY THAT PUTIN ISN'T
WINNING.
>> THIS WAR HAS ALREADY BEEN A
STRATEGIC FAILURE FOR RUSSIA
ALREADY.
HAVING LOST CHILDREN MYSELF, I
KNOW FOR THE PEOPLE, IF LOST
FAMILY.
UKRAINIANS WILL ROLL OVER AND
NOT FIGHT.
RATHER THAN BREAKING UKRAINIAN
RESULT, THEY'VE STRENGTHENED
THEIR RESOLVE.
THE WEST IS NOW STRONGER THAN
IT'S EVER BEEN.
>> KATIE, I WANT TO START WITH
YOU, A LOT TO DIG INTO.
THE PRESIDENT BIDEN GIVING MANY
MIXED MESSAGES AND ALSO
ESSENTIALLY SAYING RUSSIA IS NOT
WINNING THE WAR, WE KNOW
UKRAINIANS HAVE PUT UP A VERY
GOOD FIGHT BUT THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO SITE THIS PRESIDENT
WHO SAID USE DIPLOMACY TO ENSURE
THIS WOULDN'T HAPPEN IS NOW
TALKING ABOUT REMOVING A
DICTATOR AND A WAR THAT RAGES
ON.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON HIS HANDLING OF
THIS?
>> THE PRESIDENT REPEATEDLY HAS
SAID HE HAS NO INTEREST IN
GETTING THE UNITED STATES INTO
WORLD WAR III BUT GIVEN HIS
STUMBLING STATEMENT AND SLOPPY
COMMUNICATION THROUGHOUT, HE MAY
GET US INTO WORLD WAR III AS A
RESULT OF COMMUNICATION BACK IN
THE LEAD TO MISCALCULATION WHICH
IS HOW WARS START, THE PRESIDENT
CLAIMING SANCTIONS ARE NOT ABOUT
TO TURN FROM THE ENTIRETY OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION BY THE SECRETARY
OF STATE, WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY OR NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR SAYING FOR WEEKS
SANCTIONS ARE MEANT TO DETER AND
THIS WEEK HE WAS IN POLAND
SPEAKING TO TROOPS AND ADAMANT
CLAIMING U.S. TROOPS WOULD NEVER
GO INTO UKRAINE IN A NATO
COUNTRY IN THE TERRITORY WOULD
BE DEFENDED, THE PRESIDENT SPOKE
NONCHALANTLY LIKE U.S. TROOPS
ARE GOING TO GO INTO UKRAINE.
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE FOREIGN
POLICY SPEECH TO DEFINE
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S FIRST TERM,
THE REST WAS LOST AS A RESULT OF
A STATEMENT HE MADE AT THE END
ABOUT VLADIMIR PUTIN LEANING TO
GO IN THE WHITE HOUSE FOLLOWING
UP, IT WAS HEARD AROUND THE
WORLD THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CHANGING STRATEGIES, NOT ONLY
SUPPORTING UKRAINIANS, THEY ARE
INTERESTED IN REMOVING VLADIMIR
PUTIN AND BRINGS UP ANOTHER SET
OF QUESTIONS, WHAT DOES THE
PROCESS LOOK LIKE?
WHO'S GOING TO MANAGE THE
PROCESS?
YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT
WHAT THEY SAY IN THE PRESIDENT
HAS NOT BEEN DOING THAT.
>> I WANT TO STICK ON THIS THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT, THIS IDEA THAT
THERE COULD BE TROOPS ON THE
GROUND, I WANT TO LISTEN TO THIS
SOUNDBITE.
>> IS BEEN THERE, YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE WOMEN AND YOUNG PEOPLE IN
FRONT OF THE TANK SAYING I'M NOT
LEAVING, I'M HOLDING MY GROUND.
>> HIS STATEMENT OF US SAYING
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN CLEAR WE
ARE NOT SENDING U.S. TROOPS TO
UKRAINE AND THERE'S NO CHANGE IN
OPPOSITION.
MARK MIXED MESSAGING HERE, JOEY.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF TROOPS ARE ON THE
GROUND AND WE ARE ENGAGED IN
WORLD WAR III, THIS IS SERIOUS.
>> IF WE'VE LEARNED ANYTHING
THIS WEEK, WE CANNOT TRUST THE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES TO
TELL US THE TRUTH OR EVEN KNOW
WHAT HE WANTS TO SAY AND WE
CAN'T TRUST THIS WHITE HOUSE.
THIS WEEK ALONE WE HAVE THE
PRESIDENT REFUSE EVERY SINGLE
PERSON IN HIS CABINET WHO'S
SPOKEN ON THIS ISSUE, PRESS
SECRETARY TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE ABOUT WHAT THE DETERRENTS
ARE AND WHAT SANCTIONS ARE MEANT
TO BE AND NOW IN TWO DAYS WE GET
TROOPS ARE OR WILL NOT GO INTO
UKRAINE, WE ARE OR NOT GOING TO
USE CHEMICAL WEAPONS, A VERY
SPECIFIC THING TO SAY.
NOW WE ARE ARE NOT GOING TO
SUPPORT THE REGIME CHANGE IN
RUSSIA.
THIS IS GARY TIMES AND NOT THE
WAY YOU WANT THE PERSON IN
CHARGE TO BE TALKING ABOUT THESE
THINGS AND THE FACT LARGE
PORTIONS OF THE MEDIA WILL ALLOW
THEM, THESE ARE NOT GAPS, THESE
ARE INCOHERENT THINGS THE
PRESIDENT SAYS AND I WOULD HATE
TO BE IN FRONT OF HIM LOOKING
HIM IN THE FACE SAYING WHEN YOU